donc tout ce qui descend aura moins de
16 donc froid aura des fruits plus
petits euh
indirectement donc tout ce qui redescend
hop pas de pitié on coupe bien que les
récoltes souhaitent terminés Antoine
freymin ne chôme pas c'est arboriculteur
de 33 ans a fondé les vergers de la haie
en 2017 à Villepreux sur sa parcelle de
pomme biologique de 4 hectares environ
50 tonnes de fruits ont été cueillies en
2022 dalinette Melrose ou encore opale
23 types de pommes sont cultivés sur ces
terres on a pris beaucoup de variétés
plutôt récentes qui maintenant on les
critères de des maladies et qui sont
plus adaptées au bio avant on avait des
pommes qui flétrissaient qui devenaient
un peu farineuses ça passe plus du tout
maintenant aux consommateurs un ouvrier
agricole aide Antoine sur la partie
exploitation les pommes sont
conditionnées avant d'être proposés en
boutique ou expédié il prépare ce jour
plus d'une centaine de cagettes pour la
coopérative biodiles de France grâce à
cette calibreuse ça pèse le poids et
après ça tombe dans le dans le bac
au niveau du réglage que le responsable
a fait ici à la machine ces pommes de
variétés Brie burn peuvent être
conservées plusieurs mois dans cette
chambre froide d'une capacité de 80
tonnes grâce à un froid humide réglé à 2
degrés Celsius le fruit ne se dessèche
pas on récolte principalement pas la
hausse encore un petit peu en caisse
donc tout ça c'est en attente d'être
trier vendu et là de l'autre côté
on a toutes les caisses qui sont prêts à
être vendus qu'on doutait passer à la
calibreuse à l'origine nos
grands-parents étaient déjà dans
l'arboriculture ils étaient sur
Chambourcy mes parents se sont
développés sur Feucherolles d'Avron et
puis nous bah on reprend ici à
Villepreux cette boutique ouverte elle
était 2022 au sein de la ferme attire
une centaine de clients par semaine les
pommes mais aussi les poires d'Antoine
cultivées à Feucherolles prennent place
sur les étales entreprises familiale
oblige on y retrouve les légumes bio
cultivés aux Mureaux par son frère la
D98 c'est quand même une route très
passante donc les gens regardent enfin
sont curieux viennent voir et puis
évidemment vu que c'est bon il reste on
veut pas faire les usines à pommes comme
certaines exploitations ou ils mettent
de l'engrais de l'eau et ça fait du
navet et nous c'est quand même le goût
qui est primordial
sur la quantité depuis fin 2022 ces
fruits sont proposés dans les écoles et
la maison de retraite de Villepreux
environ 7000 pommes sont commandées
chaque mois pour la restauration
collective de la commune